what's going on guys this is Rob and I
need you guys to do me a huge favor and
go to the link down in the description
for WatchMojo they have a top ten list
for comic book YouTube channels and
right now my stuff Vinny and Sal are
definitely in the top ten in fact we're
in the top five and we're really excited
about that but what we're hoping for is
that you guys can upvote us all the way
to the top and get us to the top three
spots preferably Marvel explained and
then any combination of Benny and Sal
that's fine whatever you guys choose to
do but more will explain these to be
number one but seriously if you guys can
can check that out and see if we can get
us to the top that would be fantastic
so so that's it that's really all I
wanted to say I love you guys and I'll
catch you guys later peace